Wow!
What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
We are back with another episode of Challenge Pongfinity
Let's go!
I think it's not going to work but...
Let's give it a go!
I got it
Drop shot!
Missed the smash
There is a lot of parts that you can hit it with
You can also spin the wheels!
Oh, what a shot!
Come on!
That's enough of the chair!
Okay, every shot has to bounce on your own
side first!
Snakes!
Good save!
Long rally!
This is really intense!
We just need to put this point in the video!
Come on!
Miss already!
No!!!
How many shots was that?
Somebody count that please
This was quite fun
It's just really hard to finish the point
Just endless rallies
Endless points
So as you know
Miikka likes to move quite a lot
So I think it's time to stabilize him a bit!
I can do like very gentle footwork
Miikka is looking quite like me right now
Looking good!
Good technique on the backhand at least
How is the forehand?
That's good also!
I've got it now!
You look just like Otto!
I'm not sure is that a compliment or an insult!
I'm not sure which one is it?
Now I found the right spot
I can do anything now!
Oh, 2 in a row!
See, I almost saved it!
Okay Miikka, time for some more
Oh it's swaying!
It's swaying a lot!
Alright, last one
Oh dear
It's falling!
No, it's not
Keep it!
Okay, we are done with the challenge
So this is one of the most requested ideas on our channel
We finally got enough fans to make this happen
As you can see
We have got some air condition equipment
Well, just start placing them somewhere
Well, that started promising!
This is looking already quite interesting you could say
It's not so powerful
No, it's not on now
Ah, well no wonder!
Okay I think everything is ready now
So it's time to put the fans on!
Wake up the wind guys!
What do you guys think
How will this go?
This is our cable jungle
This one's not a very good fan
Oh, I pressed it off. That's why.
I'm sorry I yelled at you!
Where are they going?
Ok, let's see if it has any effect
Not that much
Maybe if we play lower?
We need to make it stronger
Ok now that should be a bit nasty
So we have 9 fans directed onto one side
It's still not too windy!
It gives a little kick at the end but...
There you can see it, swaying a bit in the
air
I'm trying to feel what are the windy spots
Maybe play here?
Maybe there should be one guy controlling these with hands
At least you don't get too hot while playing!
It's very refreshing
It's not that big of a difference to be honest
I'd say let's try having all the fans blowing
in the same direction
It looks normal to me!
No, it just isn't working
We would need more powerful fans
Okay, if this doesn't work
Then nothing works!
No! It's still not working!
No effect at all
I mean it doesn't affect anyhow it!
It works so well!
Watch out Miikka!
Take a picture of me
We finally made it work!
There might also be wind to the other side!
So much wind on that one!
Ok, who are we kidding
It's only Otto's side spin
I think it's safe to say that this challenge is...
Or this myth is busted!
You can't change the direction with fans
No, this is the maximum power you can get
Yea, this was a really big disappointment
I hope you guys don't get angry at us if we use this as the thumbnail!
The most disappointing thumbnail ever!
Everybody will be like wow
"They put all the fans on there and it's going to be crazy wind"
But no...
So that was all for today
Don't forget to hit subscribe
And go and check out our store [pongfinity.store]
Until next time!